space the final frontier
no space the final four tacks of death
and nothingness that's what this movie
taught me it's scary gravity so gravity
is a movie starring Sandra Bullock she's
in space on the Space Shuttle with
George Clooney and a crew of astronauts
they're all working on the Hubble
telescope and then hits the fan my
hits the fan I mean a lot of debris
comes flying their way pretty much
debris and spaces it's bad news think of
Normandy Beach times a thousand after
that disaster the thing that's
harnessing her gets blasted to get
separated and she's just kind of she's
in bad shape at that point because space
is disease in danger wrapped in darkness
and silence as bones taught us yeah he
didn't agree with that final frontier
and doing the review for gravity is
so hard because the trailers are so
shrouded in secrecy you feel like
revealing anything to spoil ER and I
don't want to ruin that for you guys
because I love going into this movie and
I was like you're Sandra Bullock in its
space and that's what I know but yeah
ultimately Sandra Bullock is out there
in space she's in her spacesuit and
she's like I need to get through this
alive that's a real phobia there
are people on earth who will never go
into space who are deathly afraid of the
concept is just floating out into space
this movie sounds really boring the way
I'm describing it it's not it's badass I
was going into this movie I was like
okay it's gonna be another one of those
I'm isolated from everything got to
survive movies but this time it's really
isolated because it's really space it's
so good it's so cool George Clooney's in
the movie he's awesome I love seeing
George Clooney in this role because from
what I know he's perfect for an
astronaut I've known a couple people who
have met astronauts the way they
describe astronauts it's like it's
George Clooney in this movie he
understands that this situation is the
worst situation a human being can
possibly be in but he's like you got to
stay cool you got to stay calm
really the movies about Sandra Bullock
pulling through this impossible scenario
to stay alive which is one of those yeah
no kind of statements but this is
the underdog story anyone drifting out
into space no matter who they are
they're immediately the underdog if
they're in that situation you take james
t kirk mister outer space put him where
sandra bullock is in this movie he is
now the little underdog he's a fledgling
he knows nothing and you really grab the
scope of that I mean the scenery in this
movies you feel like you're in outer
space the stars are clear you can see
more
stars in this movie than you ever have
which is looking down on earth you you
feel like you are up there I saw the
movie in 3d usually I'm not an advocate
of 3d I'd like to think the 2d version
is perfectly enjoyable also I would like
to think it's just as good as this movie
was for me but I'm just saying in 3d did
add a bit of that Hubble telescope 3d
adventure kind of thing and I really
like that the visual effects are out of
this world
I know is easy and I couldn't resist
myself I really couldn't know really
everything looks so real in this movie
is that there's so many moment it
reminded me of Mass Effect 2 in a couple
parts you know in Mass Effect 2 the
Normandy is getting its ass kicked and
you step in between those force fields
and you can look up through the whole
breach and you just you see a planet and
you're like that is space it feels like
that throughout this entire movie this
movie is going to get nominated if not
win for best special effects this year
and the Hobbit still coming out I know
Thor is still coming out I'm just saying
gravity is going to be up there but I
had one thing in my mind that I wanted
to see in this movie specifically and I
told a couple people is I was like I
want it to be like Firefly where things
happen in space and you don't hear
anything
not only is that the case but everything
you hear is really from her point of
view when people are talking to her
Stiles like the Burger King drive-thru
idea if everyone Big Mac learned her far
from the more perfect they sound more
clear than Burger King know so it's okay
the first thing she's doing is
unscrewing this thing and it sounds like
you have your ear up to your arm and
you're unscrewing it because you can
hear the reverb up through the spacesuit
everything else though this debris is
cutting through you just see which
is really frightening it's just the fear
of the unknown kind of thing this movie
preys upon that throughout this entire
movie I felt a sensation I was really
trying to figure out what this was for
the entire movie it's just that not in
your throats not tears you're not gonna
cry but you just you feel like you're
beaming and you don't know why it really
is because you're rooting for her so
much the sensation the emotion is pride
she's just this person she's like it's
too big it's so much but I really have
to find a way through this if you feel
there needs to be a negative address for
the movie here it is when going in to
watch gravity do not drink redbull or
any energy drinks whatsoever beforehand
because you will die you'll have a heart
attack of anxiety and intensity you're
nice no nyan yeah that goes for you too
movie theaters don't sell that not
to people watching this movie gravity
wasn't
hence it was exciting it was visually
great acting was awesome Sandra Bullock
kicked ass in this movie I love the
soundtrack too I went on YouTube that
night and just listen to the soundtrack
I was like okay gravity is one of my
favorite movies of the year this movie
sunk its claws into me and I was like I
ain't moving and I want to go back and
see this movie again and gravity
absolutely is awesome tacular we're so
space thriller what's your favorite
thriller in outer space whatever it be
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more